إن
فن العمارة [موسيقى] دائمًا في صراع
ضد الطبيعة الأم
خاصة في بيئة ساحلية هنا
في نيويورك ونيوجيرسي بالإضافة
إلى أنني أقوم بالارتفاع والتحصين
ضد أحداث الإعصار ، فقد تم تصميم هذا المنزل
بهذه الفكرة حول كيف يمكنك
إحضار هذا النوع من  بساطة العيش
في شقة حديثة ذات مخطط مفتوح تشبه الدور العلوي تقريبًا
على الشاطئ عندما
أتينا إلى Seabright لأول مرة في الصيف الذي
تلا الإعصار الرملي ،
لم تكن الكثير من الأعمال التجارية في البلدات مفتوحة
لأنها غمرت بالمياه وكان هناك العديد من المنازل
التي غمرتها المياه وهُدمت ، كنا قلقين للغاية
بشأن ارتفاع مستويات سطح البحر
، وإذا احتفظت بأرض مستوية جدًا
ورفعت منزلك عالياً ، فقد علمنا
من وجودنا هنا بالفعل قبل
بناء المنزل أن هذا
سيكون هناك أوقات حيث سيكون هناك  كن
ماءًا ، وما قلناه لراد حقًا هو
أننا نريد منزلًا معاصرًا ، يا رفاق ،
توصلنا إلى الأفكار التي شعرنا بسعادة غامرة تجاهها
منذ المرة الأولى التي رأينا فيها ذلك
قلنا ، دعونا نجعل الأمر
بسيطًا ، إنه في الأساس صندوقان فقط
مكدسان فوق بعضهما البعض ويتم تدويرهما
لتحسين المشاهدات ، الشيء الرئيسي هو
الارتفاع في حالتنا ، لقد قمنا بالفعل ببناء
المنزل على ارتفاع قدمين فوق
ارتفاعات الفيضانات القياسية FEMA
بدلاً من لصق المنزل
على ركائز متينة ، سنقوم بشكل أساسي بتدريج
الأرض وتجاوز ارتفاع الفيضان ، وقد
صممنا المناظر الطبيعية للسماح للمياه
بالتحرك بشكل أساسي داخل وخارج المنزل من خلال
قناة أسفل المنزل ، كما يحتوي المنزل أيضًا
على شبكة مخفية من الصرف
يتميز بإدارة المياه تحت الدرجة
بالإضافة إلى المناظر الطبيعية التي تحاول
تحويل المياه التي قد تتجمع فوق
درجة
أعتقد طالما أننا مستعدون
وجلبنا جميع الأثاث الخارجي ،
يجب أن نكون في حالة جيدة مثل أي شخص يمكن أن يكون
على  نشعر في Jersey Shore أن
المنزل مبني قويًا وقويًا حقًا
وبفضل المناظر الطبيعية في الخرسانة ،
أنشأنا قطعة أرض هائلة جدًا في
حالة وجود مساحة كبيرة أخرى  ضرب orm ولكن
يمكنك فقط فعل ما يمكنك فعله فقط
وستستعيد Mother Nature ما تشاء
[موسيقى]